beim ablauf gibt es eine kleine änderung
nach den statements sind natürlich
wieder ihre fragen möglich aber das
sammel statement ist heute und
wahrscheinlich auch zukünftig dann nicht
mehr möglich
er will ja guten morgen zusammen
guten morgen hier im hörsaal als auch
draußen die zuhörer
ich werde die zahlen etwas langsamer
verlesen damit unsere sprachen dolmetsch
gebärdendolmetscherin frau zwiener einen
leichteren job hat zunächst wie immer
die lage weltweit haben wir mit stand
gestern entschuldigen doch stand gestern
15 uhr 181 1408 fälle in europa sind es
64 1212 fälle in italien 27 1980 fälle
und in deutschland haben wir nun 7156
fälle
es ist halt schuldigen auf der seite
okay gut die tabelle ist eine veraltete
tabelle gewesen bezüglich auf
deutschland wir haben den aktuellen
stand und den aktuellen stand werden wir
immer ab jetzt um 0 uhr aktualisieren
und der aktuelle stand 0 uhr in
deutschland am 18
dritten also heute mitternacht heute
also vor 10 stunden 8198 fälle wurden
elektronisch übermittelt an das robert
koch institut
das entspricht einer zunahme von 1.042
übermittelten fällen zum vortag
die gesamtzahl der elektronisch
übermittelten todesfälle bis zum 18 22
00 uhr beträgt 12 das ist gegenüber
gestern keine zunahme die gesamt
incidents in deutschland beträgt
momentan 99 pro 100.000 also wir haben
ein exponentielles wachstum
um das klar zu machen wir sind am anfang
einer epidemie die noch viele wochen und
monate in unserem land unterwegs sein
wird was wichtig ist dass die epidemie
in verschiedenen teilen deutschlands
unterschiedlich stark unterwegs ist wir
haben zb hamburg aktuell 19,4 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner und thüringen 35 fälle
pro 100.000 einwohner
kurz war sonst zu den übermittelten
fällen an klinischen informationen
vorliegt für 5700 88 fälle lieben und
solche informationen vor
die häufigsten symptome sind bei rund 55
prozent der erkrankten fieber bei rund
39 prozent der erkrankten schnupfen 28
prozent bei 309 fällen wurde angegeben
dass sie keine für co wird 19 bedeutsam
symptome aufwiesen
ich habe im prinzip heute keine weiteren
zusätzlichen informationen für sie ich
möchte allerdings etwas die zeit nutzen
um eine klarstellung herbeizuführen ich
wurde gestern in einigen medien damit
zitiert dass die derzeitigen massiven
einschränkungen bis zu zwei jahre in
kraft bleiben könnten
das war natürlich ein missverständnis
denn was habe ich gestern sagen wollen
pandemien verlaufen immer in wellen das
ist für diese pandemie genauso es könnte
zwei jahre dauern bis ein großteil der
bevölkerung komik 19 durchgemacht hat
immun ist und die infektion gestoppt ist
das sagen wir bereits seit wochen
pandemien verlaufen in wellen und wir
nehmen in einem zeitraum an der bis zu
zwei jahren dauern könnte wir werden in
etwa zwei wochen sehen ob die jetzigen
maßnahmen dabei helfen die verbreitung
des virus zu bremsen
es muss uns aber auch allen klar sein
dass uns dass wir uns noch länger
beschäftigen wird und es ist genauso
klar dass die getroffenen maßnahmen
immer wieder überprüft und angepasst
werden müssen
die verbreitung eines pandemischen virus
kann von sehr vielen faktoren abhängen
von denen einige auch noch nicht bekannt
sind beispielsweise ob es einen einfluss
durch das milder werden die wetter geben
wird es ist aber offensichtlich dass der
jetzige zustand nicht dauerhaft
aufrechterhalten werden kann sondern ein
extremfall darstellt wir implementieren
diese maßnahmen bzw
die bundesregierung um die verbreitung
rechtzeitig zu bremsen wie ich ebenfalls
mehrfach klargestellt habe haben wir die
situation dass wir diese epidemie sehr
früh erkannten weshalb wir noch viele
maßnahmen durchführen können
und zu diesen maßnahmen habe ich seit
wochen aufgefordert und ich werde sie
gleich noch mal explizit benennen es
gibt natürlich auch andere maßnahmen wir
werden immer schauen welche massnahmen
angepasst sind
ich will noch einmal zusammenfassen
maßnahmen zur eindämmung sind extrem
wichtig in der jetzigen lage
und sie werden wichtig bleiben aber es
gibt verschiedene abgestufte maßnahmen
und wir müssen von situation zu
situation zu entscheiden
und das ist der grund warum das
robert-koch-institut informationen
benötigt um diese massnahmen adäquat
bewerten zu können noch sehen zu können
ob interventionen erfolgreich waren oder
nicht
und in dem fall wenn nicht dann müssen
sie angepasst werden darum nochmal mein
appell an die entscheidenden leute das
sind wir alle
zunächst mal an die
oberbürgermeisterinnen landrätinnen und
landräte das sind diejenigen die vor ort
entscheiden mit welcher intensität ein
gesundheitsamt einen ausbruch bekämpfen
kann
mit welcher intensität kontakt
nachverfolgen durchgeführt werden kann
an diese personengruppen stellen sie den
gesundheitsämtern unbürokratisch
personal aus ihren verwaltungen und so
weiter zur verfügung um die arbeit des
gesundheitsamtes zu unterstützen machen
sie alle verfügbaren ressourcen frei für
dieses ziel
der kern der verlangsamung auf die wir
seit wochen hinarbeiten
die verlangsamung der pd der kern ist
die kontakt nach verfolgung durch die
gesundheitsämter und die daraus folgende
unterbrechung von infektionsketten
mittels quarantäne bzw isolierung von
patienten nehmen sie unbürokratisch
hilfe an
an die gruppe der ärztinnen und ärzte im
ambulanten bereich strukturieren sie
ihre praxen um trennen sie mögliche co
mit 90 patienten von anderen patienten
organisieren sie sich mit ihren nachbarn
praxen an die krankenhäuser
strukturieren sie ihre kliniken so um
dass sie spezielle bereich für kurvige
19 patienten nutzen beziehungsweise
einzelne kliniken ausschließlich als co
at 19 kliniken strukturieren bauen sie
ihre intensive und beatmungs kapazitäten
auf und zwar verdoppeln sie sie
mindestens bauen sie so hoch aus wie es
ihnen möglich ist
universitätskliniken krankenhäuser
sollten unabhängig von
trägerorganisationen
studierende ausbilden ärzte aktivieren
wenn sie auch jetzt im ruhestand gibt um
sie umgehend auszubilden an beatmungs
plätzen
wir müssen die kapazität der beatmungs
plätze in deutschland maximal erhöhen
und dann die mitbürgern mitbürger setzen
sie die von der bundesregierung
geforderten maßnahmen uneingeschränkt um
abstand halten mindestens 1,5 meter wo
immer sie können bitte reduzieren sie
soziale kontakte das virus wird nur von
mensch zu mensch übertragen das muss
ihnen allen klar sein und darum können
wir die fatale die übertragung eindämmen
durch dieses verhalten wenn sie symptome
haben wie fieber trockener husten
atemwegsinfektion bitte bleiben sie zu
hause rufen sie ihren arzt an und ihre
ärztin und lassen sich bereits sagen was
zu tun ist sie behalten auskunft von
diesen ärztinnen und ärzten
schützen sie und dass der dritte punkt
schützen sie bitte unsere alt und
hochhaltigen mitmenschen sowie unsere
chronisch kranken vor ansteckung und das
tun sie durch all die maßnahmen die wir
vorgeschlagen haben
ich will das ganz deutlich machen wenn
wir es nicht schaffen das programm was
wir entworfen haben die maßnahmen die
wir empfehlen und die auch die
bundesregierung erlassen hat vor wenigen
tagen
wenn wir es nicht schaffen die kontakt
und in den menschen wirksam und über
einige wochen nachhaltig zu reduzieren
dann ist es möglich dass wir in zwei bis
drei monaten bis zu 10 millionen
infizierte in deutschland haben mit
einer entsprechenden erheblichen
überlastung des gesundheitswesens wir
alle können dazu beitragen dass dieses
zahl szenario nicht wahr wird
aber unsere berechnungen zeigen eben
auch dass es möglich ist die
erkrankungsfälle durch die minimierung
der kontakte deutlich zu drücken
die konsequente uns das gelingt desto
besser also nochmals bitte unterstützen
sie die eingeleiteten maßnahmen halten
sie abstand möglichst mindestens 1,5
meter versammeln sie sich nicht bleiben
sie zu hause wann immer es geht und vor
allem auch
wenn sie krank sind halten sie die
hygieneregeln ein die sie auch alle
kennen kümmern sie sich um über nachbarn
wenn diese unterstützung brauchen wir
brauchen jetzt vernunft und solidarität
und wenn wir das haben und das umsetzen
dann können wir die erkrankungszahlen
drücken herzlichen dank
sie sagten dass in deutschland 160000 es
vor wochen durchgeführt werden
haben sie eine gesamtzahl seit ausbruch
dieser krise und zweitens sie werden es
immer wieder gefragt aber ich wollte mal
darauf eingehen warum die talsperre war
in deutschland so gering aussieht also
die test kapazitäten die wir vor etwa
drei tagen mitgeteilt bekommen haben
sind etwa 160000 und ich gehe davon aus
dass eben auch diese 160000 tests dann
auch durchgeführt werden ich kann aber
noch sagen dass die test kapazitäten
auch noch weiter zu steigern sind wenn
man im bürokratisch noch zum beispiel
den bereich der tiermedizin nutzt es
gibt in der tiermedizin in
gesundheitsämtern teilweise große test
kapazitäten weil dort ja teilweise große
ausbrüche waren ich erinnere sie zum
beispiel an die blauzungenkrankheit wo
ja hunderttausende von tieren getestet
wurde und das ist die selbe testmethodik
das heißt also wir können die test
kapazitäten weiter erhöhen
zweitens zu ihrer frage mit den
todesraten auch hier nochmal ganz klar
wir stehen am anfang dieser epidemie
wir sind einfach nur ein bis zwei wochen
vor italien um hier ein beispiel zu
sagen das heißt also wir haben einen
exponentiellen verlauf der epidemie die
zahlen werden weiter steigen und auch
die zahlen der toten
aber ich will auch noch mal sagen wir
stehen am anfang und darum können wir
jedoch die ganzen maßnahmen die wir die
ganze zeit fordern die können wir
umsetzen das heißt wir können dafür
sorgen dass wir noch mehr menschen
schwer kranke menschen versorgen könnten
in kliniken und ich möchte auch noch mal
ganz deutlich sagen dass eben vier von
fünf infizierten ja nur leichte symptome
haben das heißt also schon sehr sehr
viele menschen gesundet sind und diese
menschen sind immun und können dann
weiterhin ein sorgen loses leben haben
das heißt also es wird sehr sehr viele
menschen gegen diese krankheit
überstehen aber wir müssen durch die
erhöhung der kapazität im
gesundheitswesen und durch die kontakt
reduktion die anzahl derjenigen die
schwer krank werden auf ein minimum
reduzieren
ja ich habe alle alles was bürokratisch
machbar ist muss getan werden das ist
unsere meinung das ist die meinung von
jedermann und jeder wird genauso
glücklich sein wie ich wenn es den
impfstoff früher gibt
ich hoffe darauf ich persönlich schätze
ist realistisch ein dass es im frühjahr
20 21 sein wird ich hab' ich freue mich
wenn ich mich täusche und das früher
sein wird wir müssen ja einen
sicherheitsprofil haben ja also wir
müssen ein sicherheitsprofil haben auch
impfstoffe können ja nebenwirkungen
haben aber es werden an allen möglichen
konzepten gearbeitet das können sie
glauben sowohl auf ebene der whu als
auch auf zulassungs ebenen der eu
fd deutschland das ist also sie können
davon ausgehen dass alles was möglich
ist ohne aber die gesundheit von
menschen zu gefährden getan wird
es gibt auch in der videobeobachtung
berufs und für einige tage das ist eine
erfahrung die wir gar nicht so selten
haben bei viralen infektion im mund und
rachenbereich ob das spezifisch ist oder
besonders häufig so einfach bei corona
virusinfektionen wissen wir noch nicht
es gibt erste hinweise dazu dass es ein
forschungsgebiet an dem wir natürlich
auch arbeiten
naja dieser könnte sein müssen wir erst
mal untersuchen werden wir sehen ob das
so ist wenn es so wäre wäre es gut
sie sagten gestern die bürger sollen
sich die hände waschen intensiv so oft
sie können in ihren eigenen empfehlungen
auf der website des
robert-koch-instituts die sogenannten
krinke empfehlungen zur in der
infektionsprävention schreiben sie genau
das gegenteil dort schreiben sie
händewaschen sind auf ein notwendiges
minimum zu reduzieren und stattdessen
die hände zu desinfizieren weil die
hände waschen
die mikroorganismen nicht ob ein
unkritisches niveau reduzieren können
das jo erste frage wie kommt es zu
diesem zu dieser also diesen absoluten
widerspruch
die zweite frage wäre dann können sie
bitte einen literatur stelle angeben aus
der erfolg dass man sich mit
händewaschen derart schützen kann dass
die viren keine ansteckung mehr bedeuten
auf den händen und dann würde ich gern
noch wissen die wer sagt dass die hände
war schon die viren sogar abtöten kann
sind sie auch der meinung also die
literatur stelle kann ich ihr nicht
geben habe ich nicht im kopf für ein wo
ihn besorgen können zu den klinko
empfehlung das ist ein missverständnis
dass ich gerne aufklären die klinke
empfehlungen sind für ärzte und personal
in krankenhäusern
was sie alle verstehen müssen und das
ist vielleicht auch nicht immer so
einfach
wir reden einmal über den umgang mit
patienten in einem hoch infektiösen
gebiet also
wir sind in einem krankenhaus sie haben
zum beispiel nosokomiale infektion und
ist natürlich klar dass sie in dieser
region wo also wirklich eine hohe last
ist von krankheitserregern also im
direkten umfeld von patienten dass sie
dort natürlich deutlich höhere
hygienemaßnahmen fahren als im
häuslichen umfeld
da ist natürlich alles muss alles getan
werden um die viruslast oder
irgendwelche anderen krankheitserreger
massiv zu reduzieren
wir sagen dass aber auch im häuslichen
umfeld wenn ein patient behandelt worden
sind ja auch zuhause menschen die krank
sind wenig schwer erkrankt sind die zu
hause behandelt werden können auch dann
empfehlen wir natürlich dass auch in
diesem patienten nahen umfeld der
infektions mittel genommen wird aber
wovon wir reden ist der normale umgang
dass menschen dadurch dass sie zum
beispiel niesen oder husten dass sie
bitte in ihre armbeuge niesen oder
husten und nicht in ihre hände weil in
den händen dann natürlich während sein
können und darum geht es diese viren weg
zu waschen
selbstverständlich können sie auch ein
teil der viren mit waschen einfach
abtöten aber wir reden hier über mengen
wir reden hier über absolute zahlen über
quantität quantitäten und qualitäten und
das heißt es geht darum dass sie die
menge dieser infektionserreger so stark
wie möglich verringern
denn etwas ist auch wichtig in der
biologie gibt es nicht dass jan ein
prinzip sondern ist immer eine frage von
menge das heißt es gibt losen von
infektion also das heißt infektions
dosen und sie können durch ein gutes
händewaschen wir sagen etwa 20
millisekunden hände waschen können sie
die dosis von infektionen und die viren
so stark reduzieren dass sie für die
übertragung keine rolle mehr spielt
die deutsche telekom hat daten data
ströme verfügung gestellt dadurch kann
man wohl die ausbreitung vitamin
modellieren und das ist sicherlich von
nutzen aber individuelle daten in die
virtuelle bewegung werden nicht
weitergegeben aus privatrechtlichen
kunden genau sowas wird aber in
verschiedenen asiatischen ländern
gemacht um stelle zurückzuverfolgen bei
kontakt kontakt racing hand zu betreiben
von und auch qualität maßnahmen zu
ja
den pfosten wie nützlich ist in diese
daten für sie und ich
diese wurde schon wahrscheinlich
gestellt aber er ist nicht wünschenswert
die möglichkeit individuelle fälle
laufwege und kontakt mehr genau zu
verfolgen
die sollten es ist weil man an entlasten
also ich möchte ihn gern dazu etwas
sagen sie sie haben sie haben verstanden
welche daten dort für das robert koch
institut zur verfügung gestellt wurde
sind nämlich kreierte anonymisierte
daten und keine individuellen daten
das wurde leider teilweise in der presse
falsch dargestellt warum sind die daten
für uns nützlich
die daten zeigen uns ob insgesamt die
mobilität der bevölkerung nachgelassen
hat das heißt also anhand der daten
können wir feststellen ob die maßnahmen
die wir fordern und die die
bundesregierung fordert ob die maßnahmen
auch eingehalten werden das ist ein
wichtiger wert denn wir müssen ja
beurteilen wenn wir jetzt
infektionszahlen in der zukunft haben
wir wollen ja bruchteilen warum die
infektionszahlen sich reduziert haben
oder erhöht wurden wenn wir sehen dass
die menschen die maßnahmen gar nicht
umsetzen das sehen wir anhand dieser
aggregierten daten dann wissen wir
den grund dafür dass die intervention
die wir wünschen nicht erfolgreich ist
denn wenn die menschen weiterhin sich so
mobil verhalten wie sie es bis vor einer
woche gemacht haben dann wird es schwer
das virus einzudämmen
das heißt also damit können wir wir
brauchen ja immer die müssen immer
überlegen wie wir wollen ja immer
faktenbasiert wollen wir entscheidungen
treffen wollen wir empfehlungen geben
und wenn wir uns nur verlassen darauf
wir haben natürlich lieber
objektivierbare daten dazu und das sind
natürlich tolle ströme wir können dann
ich weiß nicht ob jemand vorgestern im
heute journal
dieses bild gesehen dass diese ganzen
punkte sich bewegen wenn man die punkte
verlangsamt dann verlangen sagt man eben
die ausbreitung der epidemie und das
können mit diesen daten sehr gutem essen
ich denke dass das ich glaube das kann
ich nicht sagen ich glaube dass wir die
immer wieder bekommen aber wie oft das
ist das da bin ich nicht informiert
also wie kann man sowieso kaufen wie
kriegen sie nur diesmal umsonst ja das
ist eben in der krise macht man eben
dinge möglich die sonst vielleicht nicht
möglich sind
nochmal ganz grundsätzlich zum
sprachgebrauch also wie man zum beispiel
infizierte person bezeichnet die
tagesschau beispielsweise hat vor ein
paar tagen in bezug auf die infizierten
zahlen und italien 25.000 am sonntag
gesagt diese 25.000 sind an kubik 19
erkrankt ist ist sozusagen also ist es
auch geboten das so zu formulieren
das würde auch heißen dass sozial mit
einem positiven test man gleichzeitig
also automatisch erkrankt ist oder bei
sie formulieren ja meistens ist sind
fälle
was ist von journalisten die wir jetzt
einerseits informieren wurden
andererseits nicht unnötig panik
verbreiten was ist da die beste variante
die es gibt ja in jedem land fall
definition und bislang sind fälle in den
meisten ländern nur solche die positiv
getestet wurden und die mehrheit der
positiv getestet wurden sind auch krank
das hängt aber davon ab welche in welche
testung strategie man hat wir haben in
deutschland auch schon einige fälle wo
die menschen kaum erkrankt sind aber
positiv sind es hängt von der von der
strategie der testungen ab also sie
dürfen auf jeden fall davon ausgehen
dass jeder der als fall bezeichnet ist
auf jeden fall mit dem virus infiziert
ist die schwere der krankheit hängt vom
jeweiligen land und meldesystem ab und
von der intensität wie getestet wird
mit erkrankungen also studieren darf ich
viele bürger arztbesuche
krankenhausaufenthalte das muss nicht
sein also wie gesagt das können ja auch
menschen zu hause ganz leichte symptome
haben einfach schnupfen heiserkeit die
sind aber dann auch mit 19 erkrankt aber
zu hause also die die es gibt ja einen
großen grad an verschiedenen schweren
karten von erkrankung die mehrheit vier
von fünf rennen nur eine ganz ganz
leichter krank das sind aber dann
trotzdem mit 19 fälle
sie hatten
der isolierung der worte oder der
unterführung der sozialkontakte
der doktor flaschen noch etwas näher an
einem lockdown dran dann würden sie
diese empfehlung aussprechen dass sie
aus beständigkeit verhindert wird dass
man wirklich noch weniger kontakt das
bedeutet auch noch wenige kontakte mit
den nachbarn oder mit einem kleinen
umfeld der ganzen frauen na ja also wie
gesagt wir schauen uns an wie diese
maßnahme zu wirken
und ich kann nur alle auffordern dass
sie eben insgesamt zu wenig kontakte wie
möglich haben das ist ja egal ob das
nachbarn sind oder menschen die man
nicht kennt ja es geht darum wenn sich
so ein kontinuum vorstellen von vielen
tausend punkten die durch die gegend
laufen
je weniger die sich treffen desto besser
ist es und und dieses virus infiziert ja
jeden in jeder altersgruppe das habe ich
ja auch oft gesagt das heißt also
prinzipiell auf das notwendigste
reduzieren
also dass wir schauen uns an wie diese
maßnahmen wirken
darum brauchen wir zum beispiel die
daten von der telekom werden sie denn
überhaupt umgesetzt die maßnahmen und
dann muss man sich wirklich ab und an
immer wieder alle möglichen optionen
anschauen
wir können nur wissenschaftliche
informationen geben davon brauchen wir
diese daten und wir werden schauen was
geschieht
deswegen schaffen noch 3 ich habe die
daten haben also die daten wurden er
gestern uns zur verfügung gestellt
tatsächlich bearbeiten die natürlich
andere menschen und nichtig ich weiß
noch nicht
ich kann dazu nichts sagen
gute frage also zunächst mal der grund
ist ganz einfach wir haben eine riesige
mobilität in der jungen gruppe ja bei
den jungen darum ist ja auch eine sehr
sinnvolle maßnahme das mal clubs und
restaurants schließt um es ganz klar zu
sagen ja und die jungen können die alten
auch anstecken und darum muss man eben
auch sollte man sich möglichst von
seinen großeltern leben fern halten wenn
es irgendwie geht ja natürlich es gibt
doch einzelfälle es aber auch immer
wieder gesagt klar gibt es auch in allen
altersgruppen können einzelne menschen
sterben
aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass schwer
erkrankt den großen in chronisch kranken
und beim alten hochhaltigen versterben
ist natürlich deutlich höher
erstens die testergebnisse zum teil eine
woche dauern bis sie drankommen
beobachten sie eine klarheit
test kapazitäten und die zweite frage
ist es gibt einen landkreis in
süddeutschland der austria preisnachlass
sechs reisebusse die zum skifahren im
spiel waren
und die sind jetzt zurück und da sind
gestern die vorgestern anzahl der
infizierten und 50 prozent gestiegen
85 prozent gestiegen er weist klagen
beobachten sie das geschehen ist das
umdenken
also nochmal beim etwas was sehr wichtig
ist dass die tests wirklich
zielgerichtet gestern habe ich den
begriff strategisch genutzt also
zielgerichtet strategisch eingesetzt
werden es gibt tatsächlich hier und dort
engpässe aber ich gehe davon aus dass
wir durch erhöhung der kapazitäten dass
das lösen der das geschehen beobachten
wir wir haben ja festgestellt dass
tatsächlich nicht nur das spiel sondern
aus anderen skigebieten viele fälle
importiert wurden
und das ist ja auch der grund warum die
entsprechenden reisen eingestellt wurden
und skigebiete geschlossen wurden das
ist ein geschehen das wir natürlich im
auge haben und dass uns auch so gemacht
wir können das noch nicht sagen
wenn ich die zahlen sehe die testung
zahlen dann gehe ich davon aus dass die
dunkelziffer in deutschland nicht so
hoch sind wie in manchen anderen ländern
das werden wir auch erst in einigen
wochen wissen
gestern kam sie sagen ja wir stehen am
anfang einer wg und gestern kann 30 aus
hamburg von der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung die nachricht dass in
richtung wochenende möglicherweise die
schutzausrüstung knapp wird der
schlüssel sagt immerhin versuche überall
auf der welt schutzausrüstung zu kaufen
was nicht möglich sein von der
bundesregierung sei nicht bekommen dann
gibt es wiederum presseberichte die über
frankreich sagen sie hätten so eine
strategische reserve von 160 millionen
atemschutz masken gibt es so eine
strategische reserve für deutschland
vielleicht im rahmen des nationalen
pandemieplanes existiert so eine reserve
es gibt reserven ich kann die zahlen
aber nicht sagen aber es ist so dass
weltweit die masken knapp werden dass
die schutzgüter einfach nicht mehr
verfügbar sind ich kann ihnen einfach
nur mitteilen dass alles getan wird zum
einen masken und schutzkleidung zu
besorgen zum anderen auch immer mehr
alternative ideen entwickelt werden zum
beispiel dass man masken aufbereitet
wieder aufbereitet also alles was was
machbar ist um die ressource
schutzkleidung zu erhöhen wird getan und
dann muss bitte ich um verständnis dass
radikalen christen kürzer machen müssen
und morgen wieder in alter frische
vielen dank ja das war sie die tägliche
pressekonferenz des
robert-koch-instituts diesmal mit dem
präsident in wila und vielleicht noch
mal das wichtigste zusammengefasst
im moment ist es der stand in
deutschland so dass zehn von 100.000
menschen im durchschnitt infiziert sind
allerdings gibt es sehr große regionale
unterschiede in hamburg sind es fast
doppelt so viele in anderen
bundesländern etwa wie in thüringen ist
es gerade mal ein drittel
was auch noch mal wichtig ist das hat er
auch noch mal betont der präsident des
robert koch instituts ist dass sich
jetzt auch die ärzte und auch verein die
arztpraxen umorganisieren sollen dass
man da